you know as you see in Bollywood they
have stars that are they're basically
like royalty and people get so excited
and they want to know everything about
them and everyone has an opinion on
these bollywood stars how are those
types of notions about celebrities
similar in Japan or different versus
what you see here in the States yeah
it's um kind of similar you mean like a
Cardassian or like Victoria Beckham type
of evening zero is there a frenzy the
way I mean definitely here in the states
and also with sports people here but
like Bollywood stars it's just it's a
friends it mean it's they're fanatics
about their actors and their singers and
their dancers how is it in Japan is it
more are they more respected in terms of
giving them privacy about their personal
lives yeah we may be compared to the
value adore here maybe Japan has no back
off to their celebrity and but still
Mary depend on the region in Tokyo maybe
people respect them do you have a
privacy but there may be countryside is
the different okay because they're
people in Tokyo is kind of familiar with
this like Los Angeles sure so but
they're younger generation is following
their trends it's the same things and
then after their favorite actor or
actress has opinion maybe they followed
them oh it's their kind of similar
you